Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
and Canadian Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau just attended a special session
of the Canadian Parliament to honor a 98
year old Nazi we have here in the
chamber today Ukrainian Canadians
Ukrainian Canadian World veteran
from the second world war who fought the
Ukrainian Independence against the
Russians
and continues to support the troops
today even at his age of 98.
thank you
his name is yeroslav hunka
and I was going to say he's in the
gallery but I think you beat me to that
but I'm very proud to say that he is
from North Bay and from my riding of
Nipissing to miscoming
[Music]
and we thank him for all this service
thank you
that's what one more Standing Ovation
please the Ukrainian hero and the
Canadian hero
now it turns out
uh that person is Yara slav hunka who
had 18 decided to volunteer for the
Waffen SS
and though hunka's 14th Regiment of the
vaffin SS was not specifically found
guilty of war crimes it has been linked
to some pretty nasty stuff including a
reported massacre in huta piranyaka
which housed hundreds of Jews as well as
numerous Mass executions
the whole incident was particularly
embarrassing because Vladimir Putin's
justification for invading Ukraine was
to de-notsify the country
a problem that the Ukrainian leadership
has said does not exist a case that is
now more difficult to make since the
leader of Ukraine is on camera giving a
standing ovation to a Nazi
the whole episode is just
so unbelievably funny
it's out of a movie a dark comedy
certainly but it could have been written
by Hollywood not only because Trudeau
and zelinski and the entire Canadian
Parliament accidentally applauded a Nazi
not even just because after a lifetime
of anonymity this extremely old man who
appeared so happy to have his War
service recognized by the prime minister
of his adoptive country has now been
universally disavowed and become the
living face of Nazism what is most funny
is the historical ignorance of Trudeau
and zelinski and the Canadian MPS who
put this together
the man was being honored for fighting
against the Russians in World War II
who did they think was fighting against
the Russians when he says he's a World
War II hero for Ukraine and for Canada
they were on opposite sides of the war
guys this should not
sorry I'm sorry I've got to get it
together this should not have been a
surprise
as Justin Trudeau never opened a history
textbook probably not
probably none of these people have taken
much time to read history which is
probably why we're all doomed to repeat
it I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show speaking of
switching sides AOC is called on
Democrat Senator Bob Menendez to resign
she is turning on her own fellow
Democrat we'll get to that in just a
moment first though speaking of lapses
in memory
and the Nazis Joe Biden just a few days
ago
was at a New York campaign stop and he
told a story about the whole reason he
ran for president in 2020. the whole
reason he's president right now
and the story was that Donald Trump
called neo-nazis very fine people in
Charlottesville
and we've heard this before it was the
very first piece of rhetoric from
Biden's 2020 campaign
so he gets through this spiel
and then
about five seconds later
he just repeats the Spiel again
he repeated almost word for word the
very same story
to the very same small group of people
the best part is the most fitting part
for Biden is that it was not true either
time because Donald Trump did not call
neo-nazis very fine people at
Charlottesville he specifically said I'm
not talking about neo-nazis I'm not
talking about white supremacists they
should be condemned totally
but he repeats it Joe Biden obviously
doesn't care one iota about the truth
and that's been true for his entire
career but for most of his career he was
able to get by with the slick rhetoric
of a career politician now that's
beginning to fade and he's just doing
the thing that old people in the throes
of senility do which is repeat himself
this is a big problem for the Democrats
because you don't nominate Joe Biden for
president because of his conviction he
doesn't have any convictions that in
fact you nominate Joe Biden for
president specifically because he has no
convictions and he can be an empty
vessel for wherever the party wants to
go you don't nominate a candidate like
Joe Biden for his Youth and sexiness
okay he he gave that up a little while
ago Joe Biden is just the symbol of
normalcy
a return to the old ways after the
tempestuous years of trump
Joe Biden doesn't know what room he's in
or what his name is then the normalcy
argument goes away
Joe Biden is a good politician because
he can glad hand and he can backslap and
he can simper and he can repeat the
talking points that's the only Talent
the man has in politics and if he can no
longer do that then he's good for
nothing if the salt loses its Savor then
it's good for nothing it needs to be
thrown out and draw it underfoot
which is why Democrats are beginning to
look for Alternatives and the window is
closing I mean if someone really wants
to make a move for the 2024 race in
either the Republican camp or the
Democrat camp they're going to have to
do it within about five weeks or so
but certain candidates are beginning to
position themselves to do that Gavin
Newsom
governor Patrick Bateman over there in
California
has just vetoed a bill that would have
made judges consider parent affirmation
of
during custody battles this was a very
controversial bill
but it was sailing through the
California legislature and then Newsome
who is quite Pro in his rhetoric he
shuts it down and why did he shut it
down because Gavin Newsom is preparing
to run for president
now this should scare all of us because
he's been terrible for the economy of
California the economy broadly is not
doing so great which is why you got to
check out Birch gold right now text
Knowles to 98 98 98 Vladimir Putin
called the US Dollars drop in dominance
objective and irreversible as Brazil
Russia India China and South Africa
formally agreed to use local currencies
in trade instead of the US dollar as
demand for the dollar weakens the buying
power of the dollar weekends that is why
Birch gold is busier than ever investors
and Savers are looking to harness the
power of physical gold held in a tax
sheltered Ira you can too you can
protect your IRA or 401K by diversifying
with gold from Birch gold as the US
dollar continues to receive pressure
from foreign countries digital currency
and central banks arm yourself with
information on how to protect your
savings learn if gold is right for you
too text Knowles Canon WLS to 98 98 98
they will send you a free info kit on
gold with an A plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers and countless five-star
reviews I trust Birch gold to help you
diversify into gold if a central bank
digital currency becomes a reality it
will be nice to have some gold to depend
upon again right now text Knowles Canada
98 98 98
what did Newsom say when he vetoed the
bill
he said he feared that the bill might be
used to limit the civil rights of
vulnerable minorities
now this is really brilliant political
stuff
because Gavin Newsom knows that he can't
come out and say hey
you can't say that
that's not that's not how our moral
language Works in America anymore the
only moral cause that that we can make
in Liberal public life is for the rights
the supposed rights of aggrieved
minorities that's the only way we can
talk the Civil Rights language is the
only moral language left in mainstream
America so that's what he did what does
he even mean by that the civil rights of
vulnerable minorities does he mean
traditional Catholics does he mean
Orthodox Jews who don't want to
probably not
but it just sort of sounds good oh yeah
it is true and I'm I'm sure by the way
that there are plenty of black guys who
don't want to
I'm sure there are plenty of Hispanic
immigrants who don't want to
so it does work for the favored minority
groups of the Democrats but the groups
that are most interested in not
are
traditional people people who practice
Christianity people who practice Judaism
who take their religious life seriously
and so Newsom can use this line and it
just it sort of squeaks him by he then
says I appreciate the passion and values
that led the author to introduce this
bill I share a deep commitment to
advancing the rights of Californians an
effort that has guided my decisions
through many decades in public office
that said I urge caution when the
executive and legislative branches of
state government attempt to dictate in
prescriptive terms that single out one
characteristic legal standards for the
judicial branch to apply other minded
other minded elected officials in
California and other states could very
well use the strategy to diminish the
civil rights of vulnerable minorities I
challenge anybody
to decipher that gobbledygook
can anybody does anybody speak
liberal con man so that you can decipher
what that nonsense means
that is such mealy-mouthed well I
actually agree with everybody and you
know really man
and it's so ridiculous that it might
just get him elected president because
the last time that I heard gobbledygook
jargon that good
was Bill Clinton this reminded me of
Bill Clinton right after the Gulf War
the first Gulf War in the 90s
when Bill Clinton was asked the Gulf War
was very successful it was controversial
at the time it was very successful
George H.W bush was starting to take
some credit for it and in the 92
presidential race Bill Clinton kept
being asked would you have supported the
Gulf War or not you were unclear on your
feelings on the military action and his
response
it's always stuck with me he said what I
said was that I had a great deal of
sympathy with those who were arguing
that sanctions had not been given
adequate time
but that the Congress could not afford
to go on record in my judgment
undermining the U.N position that the
war was legal on January 15th and that I
thought the Congress should vote to
support the U.N resolution to make the
war legal on January 15th and that they
could argue tactically if they wished
whether hostilities should commence on
the 15th or on some later date oh yeah I
feel your pain uh
thought what what a masterful piece
of political rhetoric
what he's saying is do you support the
gulf Wars well listen I I I've I've
sympathized and agreed with the one side
of the debate and I also sympathied and
agreed with the other side uh leadership
uh that's right that's me and and
Newsome is doing the exact same
thing
Newsome is so clearly copying the Bill
Clinton Playbook that he is now even
adopting Bill Clinton's Economic Policy
vis-a-vis Republicans Ronald Reagan in
particular's Economic Policy he made
this clear on Meet the Press you look at
that trip and it made you think nicely
of Nixon and Reagan why just makes me
think that we've lost
I've just dumbfounded when I think about
the Republican party today and how far
they have fallen from Reagan reaganism
Reaganomics in some respects
um how different the party gets today I
mean the idea that you would have
Republican president that supported
Endangered Species Act the Clean Air Act
and created the EPA in Nixon the fact
that the modern environmental movement
in many respects started with Ronald
Reagan in 1989 he was out there
promoting Reagan assault weapons ban he
was defending the LGBT community
he's pretty good he's pretty good he's
leaning into being the moderate Democrat
candidate who is still
he's still supporting the far left of
the party he's still Pro
he just told you he's still really
approached he supports rights that he's
got a deep commitment to it but he
recognizes look this might this might be
used to harm vulnerable minority groups
so we got to be careful here oh yeah I'm
a tried tried and true Democrat but I
love those old Republicans you know this
whole I love Ronald Reagan I love I even
love Richard Nixon what happened to that
Republican party gosh golly
and then the Clincher for me is he says
even Reaganomics
usually if the Democrats were ever going
to praise Reagan they'd say I I like his
Sunny disposition but his Economic
Policy was evil because it let those fat
cats get rich
and it it was trickle-down economics or
whatever slogans they use
now today the Democrats simply are the
fat cats so I think they have more of an
incentive to align themselves with
Reaganomics
but the adoption of Reaganomics was one
of the brilliant aspects of Bill
Clinton's political career
Bill Clinton said I'm a new democrat
after the 1994 Republican victory in the
House Bill Clinton came out he said the
era of big government is over and this
became the standard for Western
politicians especially in the
anglosphere you then had Tony Blair who
was elected as a laborer a liberal
left-wing kind of leader but he was he
was just the Bill Clinton of Great
Britain a little bit more moderate
especially on fiscal policy a little bit
more pro-growth
and socially fairly liberal
and that typified
the 80s through the 90s really into the
early 2000s
and that was smacked down with the
presidency of Barack Obama who was a far
more radical than the Democrats who came
before him and it really reached the end
with with Donald Trump
who turned his back on some key aspects
of Reaganomics
and Reaganomics is a little distinct
from the actual economic policies of
Ronald Reagan because the promoters of
Reaganomics like to forget that Ronald
Reagan increased tariffs on steel for
instance like to forget that Ronald
Reagan used protectionist policies when
he felt it was in the National interest
but
Donald Trump said no we want
mercantilism for the 21st century Donald
Trump said we want we want more tariffs
we want to keep more manufacturing here
in the United States we want I stand
with workers we want to raise wages for
workers
that's that's what is now called
populism on the right
so the question for
Newsome is
is America ready for Bill Clinton again
is America ready for the 80s through the
90s again are we sufficiently nostalgic
the election of Joe Biden was well
if it was
if if the man all right I'll leave it at
that I want to remain on social media
platforms today but uh if Joe Biden were
elected president uh the reason for it
would be this longing for a return to
normalcy well what does normalcy mean
does normalcy mean Gavin Newsom that is
what he is betting on and that
clintonian kind of policy fiscally
pro-growth and socially liberal I don't
like it I don't like the socially
liberal part I think it destroys our
whole civilization I think that the
decay of that is evident all around us
but it has been electorally successful
speaking of that social liberalism
there's been a debate that's erupted on
the right
that debate is over marriage and I think
I might be somewhat responsible for it
because you know we put out some extra
content on the weekends and often I'm
reacting to different people in the
culture and I I don't really know
anything about these people it's usually
my producer Ben Davies and Professor
Jacob associate producer will find these
clips and say Michael what's your take
on this
so one of them was from these guys who
were part of the red pill movement and
the red pill movement is this
movement of men who are basically sick
of the way that Society treats men
at which is fair enough Society treats
men in a rather unfair and unjust way
but their response to this is to not get
married they say marriage is really bad
because the family courts and divorce
favors women and men can be completely
destroyed and have their finances
emptied out and not get to see their
kids and it's just absolutely brutal so
better not to get married at all
and I have a great deal of sympathy for
these guys because it's true I mean
the the liberalization of divorce has
been probably the greatest evil
perpetrated in our country in the last
hundred years
probably I mean it's just because it
just it just first cracked up the
fundamental Institution
of politics which is the family and the
institution most dear to all of our
hearts and it led to then the further
collapse of marriage down the line with
its radical redefinition
but that starts with divorce
we focus on no fault divorce which is
obviously a contradiction in terms a
divorce is a violation of
one of the most sacred agreements that
you could possibly make so somebody's
got to be at fault maybe it's both of
you but it's certainly not no one and
the way that divorce works now is that
men get destroyed and they can lose
their kids and there's really nothing
they could do about it so that's all
true and I agree that should be legally
changed and I have sympathy for the guys
who've been burned this way but they're
they're
whining and their suggestion that
there's nothing to be done about this
and they're really perverse uh
conclusion that men shouldn't get
married at all is is just deeply wrong
it's the flip side of feminism and uh
it's wrong because man is a social
creature and a coupling creature and men
need women and women need men and we
want the the love between men and women
to be so real that it creates another
person we want that bond to be
indissoluble what God has joined let no
man separate so just as some really
practical advice for these guys in the
red pill movement I would point out yes
it's true divorce rates can be very very
high depending on which statistics you
believe it could be over 40 percent
that's true
the divorce rate for Catholics is
significantly lower than that and that's
for all Catholics that's even the Joe
Biden Catholics who clearly don't
believe key aspects of their faith
that's for the cafeteria Catholics who
pick and choose that's for the types of
Catholics who have been
pulled away by the tides of liberal
modernity and even when you consider all
of the Catholics the divorce rates are
much lower but then when you look at a
subgroup the so-called traditional
Catholics meaning the people who still
believe the faith the way that the faith
was taught and practiced for two
thousand years those divorce rates drop
to next to nothing
okay so I agree with you that yes the
the we have a political problem that
that our political leadership is trying
to destroy the family and largely has
but there are things that you can do if
you practice a religion that not only
forbids divorce but denies its very
possibility then your likelihood of
being divorced is going to be greatly
diminished down next to the point of
nothing
now that means that you have to
you have to not just reject the parts of
liberal modernity that you especially
don't like like divorce law you have to
reject basically all of it you have to
reject the feminism you have to reject
the hyper individualism you have to
reject the uh cultural and moral
relativism you have to reject the
secularism you've got to practice a
rigorous religion that will not that
will
to tell you that you are you are
severing a very very sacred Bond
and that there is no remarriage
afterward and there's no second act and
there's no well we'll just move on that
you are married to this person until
death do you part so help you God that
is going to be one way to put yourself
in a position where it's probably not
look all of life has risk but that's
that's probably going to put yourself in
a pretty solid position
but it requires something of you and
what it requires is that you stop
listening to guys who call themselves
pickup artists and start listening to
among other things the word of God which
is which is good advice not only for men
who have been
done wrong by our present political
situation but for the whole
civilization we need some renewal and
when you need renewal in your windows
you need Renewal by Anderson right now
text Knowles to 200 300 for most
homeowners window replacement is not
something they've done before for many
it is not something that they want to do
but something they have to do if you
have put off replacing the windows in
your home because it's too expensive
I've got great news you can now get a
free in-home window consultation and a
free price quote from Renewal by
Anderson Renewal by Anderson signature
Services committed to giving you the
best customer service possible the best
experience of all supported by the best
people
in the industry a superior process and
an exclusive product I have heard from
Carpenters
the guy wrote In To Me said Michael I'm
a carpenter I heard you do a read for
Renewal and Renewal by Anderson they
always have the best Windows of any
houses that I work on coincidentally I
have a cousin who works for them who's
been telling me for years how great
renewable Anderson is you can do it
right now check it out Renewal by
Anderson it is offering a free in-home
or virtual consultation on durable
quality affordable windows or patio
doors for zero dollars down zero
payments zero interest for one year text
Knowles Canada wlas to 200 300 for your
free consultation save 375 bucks off
every window and 750 bucks off every
door won't last long so text rolls to
200 300 nulls to 200 300 texting privacy
policy in terms and conditions posted to
sexplan.us taxi enrolls you for
recurring automated text marketing
messages message and data rates may
apply reply stop to opt out go to
windowappointmentnow.com for full offer
details when Dr Jordan B Peterson made
the decision to join daily wire plus it
was a major win for those who Champion
intellectual debate with one year of
unparalleled output his contributions
have set new standards and remain
unmatched by any other platform daily
wire plus now has a vast array of
exclusive Jordan content offering
hundreds of hours of captivating content
that you won't find anywhere else
Jordan has created thought-provoking
works that reshape your perspective on
life which include vision and Destiny
marriage and Dragons monsters and men
Additionally you can immerse yourself in
discussions that nurture your spiritual
side such as logos and literacy and
Jordan's groundbreaking series on the
book of Exodus I have not even mentioned
his Beyond order lecture series or his
extensive Archive of lectures and
podcasts this is the absolute compendium
of all things Jordan plus there's even
more exclusive content on the horizon
this is only the beginning by becoming a
daily wire plus member you will embark
on an unforgettable experience that will
fuel your thirst for knowledge and
Inspire personal growth like never
before go to daily wire.com subscribe to
become a member today
speaking of breaking up
AOC is breaking up with Democrat Senator
Bob Menendez and calling on him to
resign
should he resign and what do you think
of his statement that it has to do with
him being a Latino well you know I think
it's the situation is uh quite
unfortunate but I do believe that it is
in the best interests for Senator
Menendez to resign in this moment as you
mentioned consistency matters it
shouldn't matter whether it's a
Republican or a Democrat the details in
this indictment are extremely serious
they involve the nature of
of not just his but all of our seats in
Congress and while you know as a Latina
there are absolutely ways in which there
is systemic bias but I think what is
here in this indictment is quite clear
and um and I believe is in the best
interest to maintain the Integrity of
the seat
it's a pretty good answer why is AOC
turning on her man her her compatriot
here
well because they got him dead to rights
everyone knows that Menendez is corrupt
we've known it for a decade now at least
and because New Jersey is safe so
they'll just appoint some other Democrat
there who's probably going to be better
who's probably going to be closer to the
AOC line of thinking Bob Menendez is not
the most far left radical in the Senate
and who's probably going to be younger
who's going to be there for longer so
it's a simple calculation if you're AOC
in politics you got to know when to hold
them know when to fold them know when to
walk away no one to run and Bob Menendez
is just totally toxic here's menendez's
excuse
the Feds catch him with 480 thousand
dollars in cash stashed around his house
and stuffed into the pockets of his
clothing in envelopes they didn't even
take it out of the envelopes from the
bribes they find bars of gold I mean
they find bribes
and his excuse is this
for 30 years I have withdrawn thousands
of dollars in cash from my personal
savings account which I've kept for
emergencies and because of the history
of my family facing confiscation in Cuba
now this may seem old-fashioned but
these were monies drawn from my personal
savings account
based on the income that I have lawfully
derived over those 30 years I look
forward to addressing other issues at
trial
you know it's it's probably the best he
could have come up with
but this is so preposterous
is saying look he's saying the same
excuse that he said right away right
away when they caught him he said look
they're just coming after me because I'm
Latino I didn't even know Bob Menendez
was Latino I know he has a Hispanic last
name but you look at him he just looks
like an ordinary white guy
he looks like every mildly Italian man
that I know from the tri-state area
but he's a slightly different kind of
swarthy so he gets to say that he's
Latino and they're coming after me
because I'm Latino they waited a long
time to do it but now they're coming
after me because I'm Latino they don't
understand the only reason I had a half
a million dollars in cash stash around
my house is because I'm Latino and I
remember the dark days of Castro and
that's why I need to keep half a million
in cash around my house it was all
lawfully withdrawn from my lawful
earnings from my bank account
did he also withdraw the bars of gold
from his bank account did he did he push
I didn't know because I know you go to
the ATM and you collected you want 20s
do you want 50s do you want bars of gold
I don't that's great that's cool I'm
glad maybe I'll try that in the future
they're kind of expensive though aren't
they can you withdraw Mercedes from your
bank bank account
no I was just withdrawing it from my my
earnings how about home furnishings
how about mortgage payments can you
withdraw you could withdraw those from
your bank account but that would come
from your bank account not someone
else's when the investigators went
around this guy's house they found on
the envelopes of the bribes they found
the Fingerprints of the Crooked
businessmen who bribed him
they have got this guy completely dead
to rights and the proof that they got
him dead to rights
is Menendez just hired a lawyer to
defend him
and the lawyer he hired is the same
lawyer that Hunter Biden hired
there you go just book him at this point
this is according to CNBC Menendez has
hired Abe Lowell
to represent him in this case he already
hired that lawyer in 2015. I guess Abby
Lowell is just the Democrat lawyer who
represents crooked Dems that's it that
if you are a high-ranking crooked
Democrat who they've got dead to rights
you hire this
guy
and yet according to experts the
evidence in this case is much much
stronger than was in the 15K case so
Democrats are going to flee probably
he'll have to resign
speaking of politicians careers ending
we've got the second Republican
presidential debate coming up
Trump will not go there so it you can't
even really call it the presidential
debate in that the guy who's leading
with 53 percent of the voter more 59 of
the vote according to some polls is not
participating so anyway it's the
undercard it's the people who are hoping
that Donald Trump slips and Falls either
metaphorically or physically and uh but
one one guy is not going to be there in
addition and that is going to be
ASA Hutchinson
ASA we hardly knew you Asa has not
qualified his polling is pretty low
Doug burgum the North Dakota governor
is somehow going to appear at this
debate Doug burgum you will recall is
the man who paid people to donate a
dollar to him so if you donated a dollar
to the Doug burgum campaign you'd get a
10 or 20 gift card in return I have
friends and family members actually who
did this very thing and they said it
works so that he actually sent them the
gift card which is very funny uh so
Bergen will be there Christy will be
there the chrisons lives to fight
another day croissants uh Rhonda Santos
obviously will be there Nikki Haley Mike
Pence the vague Tim Scott that'll be at
the Reagan Library
ASA will not what differentiates ASA
Hutchinson from all the rest what
differentiates him from Doug burgum or
Chris Christie I mean he's not not guys
that are pulling very high right now
ASA Hutchinson
said that he would
that's the difference and so what we're
being told by all the genius GOP
Consultants is we gotta turn away from
the culture War issues we've got to
focus in on the bread and butter dinner
table issues
no one wants to hear about
or anything like that that is the issue
that was decisive in this case that is
the issue that destroyed ASA
Hutchinson's career
that is the issue that got Glenn young
and elected governor in Virginia that is
the issue one of two that is one of two
issues that made Ron DeSantis the number
two guy in this presidential race having
been relatively unknown just a few years
ago in Florida
this is not just some Fringe online
thing
resonates Nationwide and motivates
people to go out and vote now speaking
of Ronda Santos and debates
DeSantis and Gavin Newsom are going to
be having their own quasi-presidential
debate moderated by Sean Hannity here is
DeSantis on the debate I think it's an
important debate for the country not
like saying who's better Florida
California because that debate is over
because people have voted with their
feet they've left California and come to
Florida not the other way around he has
lost massive amounts of population no
governor in California history has ever
witnessed population loss at all on net
and he's had it and Greg because it's
because of the policies he's driving
people away but what's the future for
the country the future for the country
uh for what the left would want to do is
just double down on the California
policies and so I think it would be an
important debate I think I mean I think
he's definitely angling for it I think
Biden uh I don't think Biden is going to
step down willingly I think it's harder
to dislodge somebody uh who's an
incumbent president than people assume
it would be but I think the Democrat
establishment really really is concerned
particularly you know if they have to
run against somebody like me I think
that their view on Trump is that he will
help energize their base to come out in
ways that maybe some other Republicans
won't I don't know that's true per se
the way they're thinking it but I do
think they think that
I love the way DeSantis gives that line
he goes look look it was very trumpy in
a way he says look many Democrats are
saying that if you nominate Trump you're
definitely going to lose because all the
Democrats are going to come out and
maybe you know they're more afraid of
running against you know maybe like
another candidate whose name rhymes with
like bong to pantis you know I don't
know I don't know look I'm not saying it
I don't what do I know I'm not I'm just
saying many people are talking about it
okay and it's a good answer and it's
he's absolutely right too about the
debate the debate has already been
settled the U-Hauls are moving from
California to Florida not the other way
around
so the debate is settled Florida wins
that's that's where people want to live
that model of life is better and that is
due in large part to the policies put in
place by Ron DeSantis so he's won that
debate
but my fear is
will Newsom trick everybody
my fear is that good policy and
competence and vision and all the rest
of it
don't always win in lowercase D Democrat
politics
sometimes demagogues win sometimes
Hustlers win
sometimes Patrick Bateman over there in
California wins and so this is going to
be a really good debate I'm excited for
this debate in that it will have to be
substantive that there are no two more
different states in America right now
than Florida and California so even if
politicians especially like Newsom don't
want the debates to be substantive this
one will have to be somewhat substantive
it's two different Visions for America
and it's going to let us see if Ron
DeSantis has the Charisma to go
toe-to-toe with a very Charming Canada
Newsome is a perfect test run in this
way in that he is 100 charm zero percent
substance
100 percent slap you on the back make
you feel kind of good
zero percent effective policies for
government and flourishing
and so we'll see
if DeSantis could could beat Newsom in a
debate on the day not broadly speaking
which state's doing better but I mean a
debate on the day on TV
that could be a boost to his
presidential campaign Now is it going to
bring him from 15 up to 59 where Trump
is no it's not
in many ways DeSantis agreeing to do
this debate is an acknowledgment finally
that he is not in the same tier of
candidate as Donald Trump
it's an acknowledgment that he's not the
front runner even though some people
were describing him as a potential GOP
fund front-runner someone who could deal
a knockout blow to Trump that hasn't
panned out
and what the DeSantis campaign has been
doing for the last couple of months is
just pretending that reality is other
than it is and I thought that was a huge
mistake and it hasn't helped his poll
numbers it's only heard his poll numbers
so here what DeSantis is doing is kind
of risky because he's acknowledging yeah
look I'm not the front runner I'm not
the top I'm I'm the undercard guy and so
I'm going to be in the undercard debate
I'm not going to be debating Joe Biden
Trump is going to debate Joe Biden if
Biden agrees to do it I'm going to
debate Gavin Newsom who's he's the
undercard guy for the Democrats and
we're just going to present our show to
the world
and both of these candidates benefit
from it
and Ronda santis stands to benefit the
most though there's also a fair bit of
risk here because if Newsom beats him
then the argument for a DeSantis
candidacy is gonna collapse but good I'm
I'm glad that DeSantis is taking this
risk if he continues to play it safe
he's going to go nowhere he's going to
be the he's going to be the most
competent number two or number three guy
in the race
he's got to take bold risks
and so he's venturing a lot here but
nothing ventured nothing gained and it
could could be a good show I look
forward to seeing it speaking of
candidates we've got a new Senate
candidate in Pennsylvania
not mercifully Dr Oz
very happy about that we have a new
candidate but it's another name that
you've heard before David McCormick
who's the guy who ran against Dr Oz in
the primary last time he lost in the
primary he's running again I thought he
was basically a better candidate than Dr
Oz but
I think Republicans in Pennsylvania and
Nationwide looking at Pennsylvania are
missing a key fact about how
conservatives can win in Pennsylvania
we'll get to that in one second first
though my favorite comment yesterday is
from Daniel Plainview 2584.
who says Marina Abramovich isn't even
Ukrainian this is that witch that
zelenski appointed ambassador
you also miss the part where she's in
charge of rebuilding schools now as well
right I did see that
this of course seems to follow perfectly
from her appointment if you're going to
appoint an actual witch to a position of
power in your government you're probably
going to put the witch in charge of kids
right that's how it would be in the
Grimm's Fairy Tale
that's how it would be that's of course
that's what the witches are after
in our country around the world and
apparently in Ukraine as well
David McCormick running for Senate he's
a former hedge funder he could be a
self-fundor he's a very competent guy
he's obviously a very intelligent guy
I felt he was a better candidate than Dr
Oz in uh the last cycle in Pennsylvania
uh he wants to take over the seat
uh as Bob Casey Democrat in Pennsylvania
becomes more vulnerable as a result of
how terrible a job Biden has done
he's a fine candidate but he's socially
pretty liberal
on on the social issues
things like
marriage rock ribbidness on issues of
life
McCormick is not the most hardcore
right-wing guy in the world now the
argument for someone like a McCormick or
even for Dr Oz is well look it's
Pennsylvania
you're not going to run a far right-wing
candidate you're not going to run a rock
ribbed conservative and win there
so
just take the squish
and be happy that you get anyone with an
R next to his name
I just don't think that's necessarily
true it wasn't so long ago that Rick
Santorum was Senator from Pennsylvania
Rick Santorum one of the most
rock-ribbed
traditional socially conservative
right-wing candidates that we've had in
recent history and by the way the guy
almost got himself the nomination for
president
don't forget when he was running against
Mitt Romney
Pennsylvania liked Rick Santorum
eventually he lost but he served some
time in Pennsylvania
why can't we nominate a Santorum
you want to talk about Mitt Romney Mitt
Romney lost Pennsylvania Donald Trump
won Pennsylvania Donald Trump a much
more right-wing figure than Mitt Romney
are we really so convinced that to win
Pennsylvania you need to have some Meek
and Mild
totally acceptable
to the
liberal mainstream kind of candidate I'm
not convinced of that at all it's the
Rust Belt baby
in some ways a hedge funder is anathema
to the way that pennsylvanians view
their politics
I don't really want to diss McCormick I
think in many ways he's a good candidate
and I I would have supported him over in
Oz last time
but are there other candidates could we
get a Santorum like figure could we get
could we get a trump-like figure a
trump-like figure who is suited to
Pennsylvania
Romney lost McCain lost I don't know
where's where's the Santorum figure
we just get Santorum to run again that'd
be great I would love that uh speaking
of partisans
Maxine Waters is coming out strong
against Republicans insisting that
Republicans today are not Patriots when
you take a look at what they're doing it
shows that you know the Republicans who
have claimed patriotism claim that they
love this country they don't care if
they will allow seniors and Veterans not
to be able uh to get their disability
checks for example they don't care if
they would allow education to be
dismantle in this country they don't
care if they don't care about the people
sleeping on the streets the homeless and
they're cutting housing vouchers they're
not Patriots they are basically not only
disrupted in this country they're
destroying it and they cannot claim
patriotism anymore we who fight for the
people claim patriotism we're the
Patriots not them but the Republicans
patriotism is lost it's gone
Auntie Maxine is a little outdated on
her talking points I think she's she's
speaking like it's 2012.
she's speaking like Republicans big
issue is austerity and cutting spending
and cutting social welfare programs and
it just isn't that's just isn't the way
the Republican party is functioning
today
Republicans are not harping on the need
for entitlement reform that that was
what we did in the Paul Ryan days that
is not Donald Trump ran for president
explicitly saying I am not going to
touch entitlements you might say that's
a terrible thing because our debt to GDP
is insane right now and it's leading us
off a fiscal cliff and you might say I
disagree with Trump but even if you do
it is simply a fact that the Republican
party is not as she describes it
that's the first thing I noticed the
second thing that I noticed is that's
not what constitutes patriotism
patriotism is love of country and when
it comes to love of country it is simply
a fact that Republicans are more
patriotic than Democrats
some people are going to want to say no
neither party is more patriotic than the
other they're just we're all just we're
all friends and we're all we just have
different views on it but that no that
isn't true
what Maxine Waters said is the opposite
of the truth Republicans are in fact
more patriotic than Democrats because
Republicans love their country they love
their Nation
they have an attachment to their nation
in a way that Democrats do not because
Democrats tend to be globalists
Democrats tend to use phrases like
citizen of the world Democrats tend to
oppose the very notion of nation and
nationalism
Democrats
they have other attachments
they have attachments to the U.N they
have attachments to the humanity they
have attachments to all those things but
but not to Nation
and this is going to continue to be a
defining feature of of Elections
it's been building for almost a decade
now
the Donald Trump election was about
nationalism versus globalism it wasn't
about raise welfare spending or cut
welfare spending it wasn't about reform
entitlements reliever title entitlements
as they are it wasn't it was about
nationalism versus globalism and you saw
this on the debates over trade and you
saw this on the debates over immigration
and you saw this on the debates even
over voting and how the how the
elections would be conducted
does everybody get to do it do you get
to just enter into this country and then
you're automatically registered to do to
vote or to get an ID card or do you have
to show your ID card when you go vote or
do you have to be a citizen and prove
that you're a citizen that's what this
is about and that's what brexit was
about and that's what the election of
war bond is about Orban rather in
Hungary that's what the election of
Maloney in Italy is about that's what
this is going to continue for a very
long time now speaking of globalism
before we go I'll just give you a little
tease
just a little something to keep you up
at night
the Wuhan Institute of virology
is a warning
that another coronavirus outbreak is
highly likely
which is right about on time I mentioned
when the Democrats started bringing back
the masks a little bit here and there
Lionsgate in LA
Morris Brown College in Atlanta Rutgers
in New Jersey and now okay we're going
to bring back a little maybe mask in
public in New York okay we'll get your
booster shot we haven't talked about the
boosters in a while get your booster I
said they're doing covet again and now
here's the latest proof which is the one
on Institute of virology which leaked
the virus the first time most people
think uh says another one is highly
likely this is according to a study
published
by the wiv in July there were as many as
20 species of coronavirus that are
highly likely to cause an outbreak among
humans
especially around polling places in 2024
so watch out for those mail-in ballots I
will be in Washington tonight I'm going
to be speaking at Georgetown if you
happen to be in the DC area tickets are
free you can find them at the yaffe
website yaf.org or if you go to my
website Michael J knowles.com there
should be a link somewhere you just have
to register uh so that people can vet
you and make sure that you're not antifa
trying to blow me up uh we will be
discussing I have this very
controversial take which I knew would be
somewhat spicy I didn't think it would
be as controversial as it became which
is that I'm sorry to say that I'm
beginning to think that Joe Biden is a
more evil ruler
even than our evil opponents overseas
chairman XI in China and Putin in Russia
I'm beginning to fear that that Biden is
at least as evil and maybe more evil a
ruler than they and people reacted with
such shock and horror a senior uh
presidential campaign staff member was
was quite opposed to this and made that
clear on Twitter and uh all sorts of
people in the political media so anyway
I I'll be making my case for that
tonight over at Georgetown make sure if
you're in the neighborhood to come stop
by the rest of the show continues now
you don't want to miss it but you have a
member use code Knowles kwles to check
out for two months free on all annual
plans
foreign
[Music]